hello everyone and welcome to another
very nice game from the feeder Grand
Prix 2019 this is a game from round two
and well round two also has two
classical games as around one had to
classical games all the games in round
two in Game one were drawn so this is
game 2 let's check it out it's a rout of
Slavic versus Peter Svidler so both of
them advance to the second round and
before we check out the game we do have
a couple of nice photos there you have
Peter Svidler being checked for any you
know funny business
maybe you know and maybe he has an alpha
zero integrated into his tuxedo or
something you know you can never be too
sure and also here's a nice photo of
Roddick being checked for four same I
don't know what the the device actually
does but it probably looks for some sort
of a electromagnetic signal you know
maybe coming out of the person or
something but if any of you do know you
know do share in the comments so we can
all increase our best knowledge
and here we have a nice photo of the two
of them playing it's from game one in
round two
as you can see silver has the white
pieces here and in the game we're
showing silver has the black pieces but
it is the only one that that I have and
also if you look very carefully you can
see a wild Donald above appear in the
background there we have it
so that those were the photos I do hope
you enjoyed that now let's check out the
game so a very important game as if one
of them wins IDR one gets knocked out of
the defeated Grand Prix so what if it
has the white pieces and we have d4 on
the board Knight to f6 with c4 and the
g6 and it like I said it's a very
important tournament so it's not all
that weird that all the games in round
in run to game one ended in a draw
everyone's playing really just you know
safe lines none of the none of the funny
businesses is even a possibility here so
here of course whether it would be very
happy to see Knight c3 and b5 if he
could go into the groom fall defense
which he is famous for but erratic knows
that and of course he goes for F 3 this
is the anti groom fault and we're gonna
go into a very very nice theoretical
line
we have e 6 by sweedler efore we have C
5 now and D 5 grabbing more space in the
center we have D 6 Knight to c3 and now
comes Bishop to g7 just continuing and
here comes Knight G 2 e 2 also this
position was on the board in ding Liron
versus Alexander Grichuk in the Kashima
memorial were just captures and defy was
played but here Ziegler opts for a
different line Bishop to g7 night GTE -
preparing to go to g3 and here we have
just castles and it's a very popular
position to play very especially
nowadays there are over 500 games with
this exact same position in the database
so here sailor castles also interesting
fiddler had this exact same position
against Lebanon Aragon in Palma de
Majorca in the in the Grand Prix of 2017
where he captured on d5 but here again
he goes for a different line that game
against Lebanon and ended in a draw here
he castles and now comes Knights to g3
also that line that we've shown where he
instead of castling went eight
characters on d5 Crossan also had had
this position against the anypony
machine status till 2019
we're also it captures and defy was
played in that game also ended in a draw
so sweedler castles with night to g3 and
now e capture 75c capture some d5 and
now a6 just preparing b5 of course which
is not interested in allowing b5 so he
goes a 4 and I'll just h5 preparing this
h4 maneuver
rush up to g5 preventing h4 and now
comes the Queen to e8 Spiller on pins
here and is now ready to either do
something with the night but also the
Queen does a lot of pressure along the e
file and here with Bishop to d3 and
Rohtang also known as the penguin had
two very nice victories which Queen to
d2 one of them in last year is a world
rapid championship but ok Bishop to d3
continuing the game with Knights the h7
now pushing the bishop back push up to
f4 and now Queen to e7 just a very nice
move with the Queen and now you can go
g5 is a possibility h4 is a possibility
and you have to decide what to do here
night the GTE - making room on g3 for
the bishop if needed and here nice to d7
with castles and here we were still not
in any new territory
there is one game that comes out of this
position where h4 was played I was
between Nikita the Kiev and even chef
Marino in the Gibraltar masters of 2014
that ended in a draw but here's Fiddler
goes for Knights the e5 and it is only
as of this moment from move 15 that we
have a completely new game on our hands
so now it's you know unexplored
territory of course you don't want to
give any of the bishops you know you
still want to keep your disrepair so
let's go back to see - and now look the
be it here Spiller is ready to push b5
but a radical doesn't roll out we have a
5 and here there are a couple of lines
you could choose from now you could go
h4 and then go f5 you could go f5
instead of h4 and then prepare H for
let's say Bishop to see one you don't
want your Bishop on this line as after
the F file gets opened up so after
Bishop to see one you could continue h4
hoping for h3 white would then push
let's say h3 captures Knight captures
Bishop to a5 can be played this is one
of the lines that it was possible after
vitajex
a5 but here is fiddler wants to
forcefully bust open the B file he plays
b5 allows this a captures and b6 on bass
on with rook captures and b6 and now
just Bishop the c1 not allowing rook
captures and b2 and also we don't want
this Bishop on DF file like we already
mentioned with h4 bass fiddler and now
comes f4 pushing the knight back with
Knight to g4 and now just h3 preventing
h3 by black and also a forcing back to
decide what to do with the night we have
Knight back to f6 and now comes Luke to
a - just a nice nice rook maneuver as
you want to get this Bishop back into
the game for the moment the rook doesn't
have all that many things to do so
Bishop to e3 is the plan we have Bishop
to d7 by black maybe Bishop to b5 an
idea if black could get his pawn back
together
would definitely be an achievement and
now queen t1 just threatening to wind eh
for pawn with Knight to the h5 by
Sevilla now the queen guards the h4 pawn
and now Bishop to e3 as planned
and now rook F to be a doubling up on
the B file and here well you could
defend the b2 pawn in a lot of ways you
could go Queen here you could go Bishop
here what she goes for b3 and he allows
a very nice exchange sacrifice that is
even the engines favorite and silver
goes for it with looked after some b3
Bishop captures on b3 and rook captures
and d3 threatening to win denied here
and now you can see that well much like
in the Benoni for example you have this
very nice dragon here and also the rook
on the on the open B file complement
each other very nicely so Bishop to b2
defending the knight Bishop to d4 check
now you have to go to h2 if you go h1
the knight to g3 will be very dangerous
so King to h2 and now comes Knight 7 to
f6 and here sailor says okay I'm just
gonna start an attack against your king
feel free to you know capture my pawn if
you want I'm not interested in defending
that but it's interesting that the
engine screams that rook captures on a6
is a winning move but it's I mean it's
not not something you would play it's
one of those disgusting engine lines
where after rook captures an a6
for example Bishop c8 going after the
rook now comes Luke the c6 attacking the
bishop bishop back attacking the rook
and now just rook to f3 and this appears
to be just a dominant position you don't
really care about your rook here if
black captures you're just gonna have a
very nice passed pawn here Queen
captures on h4 is the idea now if if
Bishop characters you will capture here
and now for example rule b6 you go after
the rook not just nice d5 your attack
here here your attack here after this
gets traded off now you have a protected
passed pawn on c6 and it should be
winning for white but the boy - Shrek
trusts viddler he says okay I'm just
gonna prepare that we have looked to f3
and now maybe I'm just gonna capture the
a6 pawn on the next turn and here
sweedler says well if you haven't
captured it on the previous turn I'm not
gonna defend the
now so just look the b4 and here a
Voyager could capture that with route
captures and now look the c4 here a
thriller has some ideas of busting open
in the center of the board but avoid
effect prevents it we have rook to a7
pinning the bishop here as the Queen on
e7 would be taken with Queen to d8
getting the Queen out of the way
but now comes Queen to a-1 and now you
can see that the rook to e8 is the
threat so what do you play here here you
could go for Queen t7 just getting the
Queen out of the way but then you get
Bishop t1 and going for the h4 pawn and
here after g5 defending you would get
Queen to a6 just going after that rook
and c4 and now you would either have to
give up yet another exchange or you
would have to go rook to e4
but then gets F capture Sun g5 attacking
the knight and here white is just
completely winning there's not much
black can do if you capture here you're
just gonna get captures Bishop e5 chick
king - h1 and now rook captures on e4
but then white can just play queen d3
attack the rook and after the rook moves
let's say here captures captures you're
gonna go Bishop captures on h4 and you
are just much better here there's no
there's no compensation for the exchange
and once the Queen moves let's say g6
can be played and white we'll just bust
open
so after this Queen - a one moves
failure decides he doesn't wanna move
the Queen rather he goes Knight captures
on e4 and it's a nice idea a lot of
pressure here are going on on the King
side towards the White King of course
the knight cannot capture as the knight
is pinned here
the Queen would be lost but he allows
rook to e8 so this was Fiddler's idea
but up to c8 and only now will I can
continue
what I've been doing in the center but
here he misses a very nice move from
Reuter Shack and it's well it's actually
a winning move for white so feel free to
pause the video here and try to find
this idea for white in this position
I'll give you a couple of seconds for
those of you who were able to do it
congratulations you are an excellent
lifter of Queens and for those you who
just wanna enjoy the show here we have
Queen - a6 and Ice Queen left that's not
even a term but you know I I have to
call it something
and now you have to see that rook
captures and see it is a terrible threat
if you capture then you simply get rook
captures and e8 check King moves but no
longer is the night pin so now
characters here will just if you count
the pieces I'll leave a white up a whole
rook so of course completely winning for
white you can't go for this trade so
silver goes for a different one with
night capture Sundy to giving up the
Queen rook captures on c8 now the Queen
can no longer move as the king is still
on g8 Knight captures an f3 with Czech G
captures on f3 and now Queen captures on
CA there was nothing better Queen
captures on see it with check King to g7
and here just Knight captures on d4 you
want to trade down as you are up so much
material rook captures on d4 and now
Queen to d8 just getting ready to
capture on d6 create a nice pass pawn
here we have looked a d2 check King to
g1 and now Knight captures on f4 and it
would be it would be nice if I mean
there's a look on the second rank the
King is on the first rank you have a
knight so some drawing chances could
exist but they don't exist here here at
Queen captures on d6 was played Knight
captures on h3 with check King to f1 by
boy to check and it was in this position
that Peter Svidler
resigned the game which is very
unfortunate as this this game now means
that he's knocked out of the field at
Grand Prix 2019 so what what could you
do here well really nothing if this
Knight was instead of let's say let's go
back of you moves if you could get this
Knight to f3 somehow then it would
indeed be a draw and it's something if
you haven't seen it you should remember
it sometimes your opponent might have
you know an extra Queen and you'll be
have you'll be having some drawing
chances so I'm just gonna play a few
very silly moves
just ignore them I'm just gonna do them
so I can position the knight by taking
each one night here King here and now if
the knight was here now Svidler would
have a draw for example Knight captures
here and now King if one you just check
him again King you want you just go
Knight f3 check Knight also defends the
rook the King has to go to f1 you just
repeat an ith to check or I mean you
could capture with the Queen but sidin
the rook is just much much stronger than
the night here can you do one you just
repeat and now you have to go back
because if you go to h1 then it doesn't
really work and then you get to look to
h2 check Queen captures on h2 you get
night tetris on h2 King captures on h2
and now you have this position where
okay white still has a night but after
King to f6 you get let's say 94 you
could go here King e5 and now it's a
well it's basically a draw if you
capture here then black can capture on
d5 you can push d6 in hopes of maybe
somehow saving the game I mean winning
the game black is not able to capture
here but you can just start pushing
yourseif your c4 pawn or not you could
go King t6 and just wait and the white
will not be white shouldn't be able to
win this game but yeah especially a nice
position to just remember the spare okay
if the Queen doesn't guard the h2 square
then it's a clean draw but with the
Queen there it's you know you have to
work for your meal but a nice position
to remember so that's the game I do hope
you enjoyed it here we have also a nice
photo of well it's not nice for filler
but you know he's very sad that how this
game turned out but you know you can't
you can't win all of them so like I said
that's the game I do hope you enjoyed it
I would like to thank VH Neil for a
contribution to my channel thank you a
lot to really appreciate it as usual you
can check - on my previous videos here
think of for watching and I will see you
soon continuing the coverage of the
feeder Grand Prix 2019 and if I manage
the chance we are also going to
simultaneously continue in the
Capablanca saga thank you all I will see
you soon and have an excellent rest of
your day